that's an excellent start try again good
morning thank you as you can hear from
my voice I love Copenhagen I'm always
glad to be back here so how many of you
built a student call applications today
or in the in the near future okay and
how many of you have to secure them like
it's your job to secure them okay so to
be honest I just did a two-day workshop
on this topic so there is more to be
said about that that fits into 60
minutes so it's an overview okay so it's
basically for people that maybe are new
to that and want to get like a big
picture what is in there in asp.net to
help me with the security architecture
of my application or maybe you know you
know bits and pieces of it and you want
to make sure you're not missing anything
yeah so we help our customers evaluate
basically if asp.net core is the right
platform for the next-generation app or
you know the app date if they're
planning to build and so on and you know
that there are many things that make up
this platform I only know about security
now that's all I'm that's all I can talk
about really so and it you know for
those who have been following a spinet
quois many things have changed right so
the the authentication system was brand
new in 1.0 got rewritten from scratch in
1.1 got rewritten from scratch again in
2.0 the good news is yeah now it's
pretty stable yeah so from from a
security point of view that that's good
news I also had a look at 3.0 the other
the current preview preview free and
again it looks pretty stable so no
fundamental changed any more at least as
of today ok you never know
so this talk as I said is no of you
after the things we have today and a
little bit of an outlook what's coming
in in 3.0 so my name is Dominic the idea
is I I have a couple of links on these
slides for demos and and documentation
and so on and I upload those slides to
speaker deck
if you wanna you know if you need one
URL then take the get the speaker take
one download the slides from there get
the the further links from there so I'm
working with the asp.net team for a long
long time I'm I'm one of the office of
this thing called identity server which
is an open-source implementation of an
oo of an automatic connect server which
is pretty close to the metal in asp.net
so whenever the asp.net team decided to
change something internally in their
security stuff
it broke us pretty much the first so
that's where basically all you know my
gray hairs coming from okay so who is
old enough to remember this how many of
these five options actually work any
idea none works you're right you mean
not the none option or none of them none
works yes which one does work to Windows
does work you would hope that right
forms works as well has anyone ever done
a passport authentication you can't
because it never existed
yeah it it was a product from Microsoft
which got pulled before the very first
version of asp.net and nobody updated
the enum okay
federated was the second attempt of
Microsoft to do token-based
authentication Internet 4.5 before they
released it they removed it again but
nobody updated the enum okay so yeah I
spent even 14 years 14 14 months of my
life
yeah documenting all this and if you get
one takeaway from this talk never write
a book ok it's it's not worth it it was
called asp.net 2.0 it got released and
three weeks later asp.net 3.0 got
released which made it outdated even if
they're nothing has changed in between
but you know so I'm assuming none of the
three people in the room that read this
book know
yeah I thought so anyways
kind of like that the scene for modern
applications yeah is kind of you know
like I mean there's nothing new right
we're building front-end for building
backends a building back and so backends
yeah it's just that you know the
technologies change the requirements
change a little bit the circumstances
change right well you know 10 years ago
this was all Microsoft Windows dotnet
today you know we have a wild mixture of
dotnet and Windows and UNIX and
containers and iOS and Android and
Chrome and Firefox and I think that's it
pretty much yeah so 10 years ago we
relied on the operating system to do the
heart-to-heart work for us right enable
Windows integrated authentication in is
chop done this doesn't work like that
anymore so basically because we have
this operating system independence and
the cross-platform and these different
runtimes all of the security stuff these
days is happening at the application
level right the protocols are at the
application layer they are running over
HTTP and and so on in other words it is
actually the top of asp.net core in your
system to provide all these things ma'am
so let's have a look how that works you
typically when we talk about a modern
security architecture factor out certain
security functions one would be
authentication so you know you would be
crazy if in 2019 you would write your
own login page inside your application
you want to make that a central you know
a shared service that your applications
can share you get things like single
sign-on you know and and and you know
basically make allow the business
developers to focus on the business and
the security guys to focus on security
ma'am so that's to be called an identity
provider and you also want to have
something that deals with authorization
so after you know who the user is you
want to know what is this user allowed
to do there are many ways to implement
that I just put it there as a separate
box it doesn't necessarily need to be as
its own server but it's definitely
separate from the identity yeah so I've
seen many people trying to conflate the
two concepts identity and authorization
and it doesn't work now I
would need another talk to explain to
you why if you're interested come to me
afterwards but it's it's complicated
okay so my idea is basically to start
from the ground up and work our ways up
the different layers of asp.net and what
the security of these layers is all
about let's start with hosting so you
might might have heard that Microsoft
built their own new web server called
Kestrel it's a cross-platform web server
and I wouldn't even call it the web
server it's more like an application
server it executes exactly one
application which is your application
it's not like I is where you have like
you know virtual directories and
application pools and all these things
so but by default asp.net core will
execute on the kestrel application
server there are more options these days
you can host an IAS and so on but if you
are not on Windows or you want to have
the same server on all of the platforms
then you probably end up using kestrel
you might have heard that writing a web
server is hard especially from a
security point of view yeah so in the in
the in the one point x times microsoft
said like yeah you can use Casper but
never ever expose it directly to the
Internet because we are not sure if you
know the wild wild west is will be
friendly enough to to our new little web
server so that has changed in in version
2 so if you want to you can now expose
kestrel directly on the edge lots of
penetration testing has been done they
found a couple of parks or many I don't
know and it is now a fully supported
architecture yeah and some people do
that I as as a security person I still
feel a little I don't know
torn here I personally prefer to have a
reverse proxy in front of my web server
they are like you know nginx Apache iis
or maybe a load balancer that's my
preferred architecture but this is fully
supported now ma'am if you want to do
that maybe you know in the micro service
context people like like the idea of
having a lean very small web server
bring it up run you know host the
service whatever if you are hosting
directly on the Internet be prepared to
tweak some things right
so Kestrel is a very small and very fast
web server but and has a lot of tweak
ability now and you have to figure out
yeah what which buffer sizes do I need
yeah which limits do I need to set yeah
and there's always a fine line between
performance and denial of service
attacks so be careful with that they now
support HTTPS and actually if you open
the newer templates they have HTTPS
turned on by default in kestrel which I
personally think is not really necessary
because I am not seeing any benefit of
running HTTPS on my localhost but well
you know it's HTTP by default now which
probably sounds good
what's pretty cool is they support both
static certificates where you just you
know have a static configuration or
their support also as an i which which
stands for server name indication where
you can host multiple the you know dns
names on the same server for example and
pay depending on what's coming in you
can get the right cert and and do the
due date DHCP s tunnel with that as well
so you know that's Castro once you are P
beyond the hosting layer or yeah the
hosting layer then you are entering the
a spinet core you know runtime if you
like which is essentially a process that
loads dotnet yeah or thought net core
right now you have to choice in the
future
asp.net free will not run on the.net
framework anymore so in my opinion you
should move away from that as quickly as
you can on top of that we have a speed
on that core then we have this thing
called a middleware pipeline which
basically is just a way to automatically
execute code now and the middleware
itself is typically pretty simple it it
pulls the real services from from a DI
container and uses their to do its job
so it turns out all of the security
features in asp.net core are actually
services living in a DI container and
some middleware that makes use of it now
if it needs to be executed automatically
in the in the request pipeline so the
first service I want to talk about is
the one that not people not many people
know but it's going to bite you
on deployment day if you are not aware
of it man who can remember this year
yeah the machine key right so the
expectation in the old days field
networks that you have a master key for
your application you have to come up
with that yourself or you go to some
website machine key generator com yeah
and then you paste that key into your
web config and then this key is used to
protect your cookies and and all these
things right so this is basically the
most important string in your in your
application because whoever can steal
that key from you he can create cookies
that look like as if they are coming
from you okay which is a very bad thing
and because this string was so important
we put it into clear text into a
contruct file on our web server right
there was a brilliant idea yeah it was a
90s design man
you know these things end up in source
control and if you open source this
thing it ends up on github if you're not
careful that Google indexes your config
files right I mean try this you have fun
yeah you probably can't deduct for that
for that means this searches in taxi I
am so that that's the first thing they
had to change okay so they have a new
API in a still called the data
protection API and the first thing they
had to fix yeah was to get that key
material outside of the application
directory yeah it must not live inside
the application directory otherwise this
will you know it's it's the the chance
of exposure is very high so that's what
they did
the FMT falls where they store it by
default and it is a very developer
friendly because on your local death
machine they just take your your your
profile and store it in there okay I
think that's a screenshot of that yeah
that's how it looks like yeah so it's in
users Dominic AppData local a spinneret
data protection keys and that's how a
key looks like mam this this API is zero
maintenance from your point of view at
development time because they just
create that file and just using it yeah
the problem starts when you are starting
to deploy the application because hey on
the deployment server this Phi
must live somewhere okay so you know if
you're deploying to Asia right I mean
they put some magic pixie dust over your
application just works yeah because what
they do a under the covers is they
provision a file share that it's shared
between all the instances of your web
app and then they put that key container
on this file share if you are doing
anything else than - web apps you have
to think about where to store this thing
and the options are in a database in a
cache blob storage whatever okay but you
have to have this thing otherwise your
applications will break the moment they
are being load-balanced right because
all of the nodes in your cluster must
have access to the same key material
otherwise it'll break okay so let me
show you a demo of that and I'm showing
you that because I have many customers
that have this unpleasant experience on
deployment day and that's the worst day
right to have unpleasant experiences yes
so basically you can see this data
protection provider is just a service
living in a DI container you can use it
yourself Microsoft uses it internally
and then you can just you know protect
data and unprotect data and let me show
that to you first and be be aware all
these demos are really really boring
because that's how security demos should
be well if security is exciting well
then it's probably in the way of many
people so you know but encrypting a
string yay okay that's that's you're
protected string now and now you can
basically transmit this or you know put
it on a query string parameter or you
know round TripIt whatever and when
you're unprotected the system makes sure
it hasn't been tampered with manipulated
and so on so forth yeah the other thing
I did in this application is something
you should never ever do probably a bad
pass introduction to the feature but I
persisted that the keys to the file
system in my current application
directory why well just just to be able
to show it to you easily right here it
is okay they'll debate every first time
I use the API it created this key
container and here it is okay so
now let's simulate your load-balancing
yeah and the application doesn't have
access to the key anymore because humble
I'm deleting it yeah so and I'm shutting
down the server as well and running it
again okay
and now imagine a cookie comes into your
application a through net tries to
unprotect it it'll fail okay it won't
fail with an unhandled exception in the
cookie case but you will see these
exceptions in your log files and that
means basically somehow you are not
configuring your key container in the
right way okay so you know sounds boring
but it's very important because as I
said the moment your load balancing this
will fail if you haven't planned for it
No
okay besides that this API is brilliant
yeah I mean they they use all the bells
and whistles big keys the right at the
right algorithms the order rotate your
keys every 90 days they do all the right
things and really the only thing you
have to do is give them a place to store
it okay good yeah so who's using that
well cookies are using it and default
areas using it Oh off the state
parameter is protected with data
protection if you think tempdata ma'am
these things you can use use yourself as
you've just seen so if you have to need
to temporarily protect certain data
while you're passing it around that's a
thing to use okay so the other
protection is actually needed by the
authentication system as you can imagine
because there is a need to protect data
now so let's have a look at that next
so the authentication system is by far
the best thing we ever had in in in
dotnet yeah it's super flexible you can
use as many different authentication
methods as you want you just throw them
in at the I container we have an
orchestration engine that makes sure no
one steps on each other's toes and for
the very first time this actually works
yeah I mean four people are doing a win
or you know other things they know that
it's a bit tricky sometimes
so basically when you when you look at
the authentication system we have a
couple of options here well one is you
do your own authentication obviously you
bring up your name and password page you
go to your database and so on
mam or you are using some sort of social
providers right like Google Facebook
Twitter and Microsoft are included by
Microsoft which are proprietary and you
see here there's a community project
which has like 40 plus more of these
proprietary providers like you know in
really important things like petal net
for example or you know github or I'm
tapped ma'am when you look at standard
space protocols Microsoft supports open
D connect obviously and W is Federation
so if you have like an ad FS server for
example or you know that's the main
motivation really to have it here or
you're working in a bank or something
like this W Federation is still a thing
sam'l is not included by Microsoft but
there's a guy from Sweden called unders
whenever you have a similar problem just
call him he's the right person to talk
to
don't call me please
and yeah he produces an authentication
handler for a spirit core that works
really well with sam'l and then the last
thing that's included is chasing depth
tokens obviously when you're doing token
based API authentication ma'am then we
have the notion of a session right
signing in a user signing out the user
and so on there's a whole abstraction
for that by default it's implemented on
top of cookies right because that's what
we do in the web but you can exchange
this implementation if you want with
something server-side yeah that's boring
that is how you interact with your
authentication system so there's s1
service living in a DI container called
the I of indication service and this
implements the five I don't know motions
that you typically do in a Web API you
are authenticating someone you're
signing someone in that starts the
session signing someone out stops the
session challenge means you signal the
system authentication is required for
bit
means that the user is not allowed to do
whatever is trying to do
despite being authenticated which makes
it different than challenge okay so
that's that we don't need to do this
session management yeah so as I said
applications are stateless right so we
need to have find a way to do state in
in in so in regards to having like
authentication sessions this is
typically done with the so called cookie
authentication Handler and it does
things you know that you would expect
like you know setting the cookie name
setting the expiration you know sliding
versus absolute and so on they support
same side cookies now out of the box all
of your cookies are same side mode legs
which means they are much more resistant
against cross-site request forgery
attacks these days yeah which is really
good and I'll show you a big demo at the
end which brings all these things
together but just to give you an idea
how how that session management works
it's basically you know you are
ventilated the user somehow or you went
to some authentication service but
ultimately you're modeling the identity
of the user as a list of claims right
that that's the abstraction that they
are using so you're creating a list of
claims you put the claims in there like
the subject ID and the name and the
email address and so on then you turn
that into a claims identity and then you
can associate additional metadata with
the authentication session which is not
claims but maybe something you want to
keep together during the time of the
authentication you know maybe you want
to store an access token for the user so
that whenever this user you know you
want to call an API on behalf of that
user you just go to the session get the
token and use that from there okay and
then you know you basically call sign-in
you pass in this claims principal you
pass in the properties and that's
basically what sets the cookie now
typically and when you're done with the
session you call sign out which then
deletes the cookie again okay
so do that how that works it's pretty
simple the cookie handler has some
advanced features so for example you can
tap into the lifetime events like for
example there's an event
gets fired every time the cookie comes
into your application that gives you a
chance for example to say like hey even
if this user is authenticated is he
still a valid user yeah or maybe someone
disabled him in the database and now
would be the time to you know get rid of
this cookie now even if the cookie
itself would be valid you can also you
know another common thing to do is go to
the sign out event so that you can can
do some cleanup at sign out time yeah
maybe you want to get rid of tokens or
clean up data databases or caches things
like that ma'am and as I said the
session storage mechanism itself is
replaceable so as I said by default
they're using cookies but as we all know
cookies have certain limitations yeah
so a cookie shouldn't get bigger than
four kilobytes and some you know
different browsers have different upper
limits how much they support per domain
and the most problematic one it turns
out is Safari but they only have eight
kilobytes per domain so if you have many
applications running on the same domain
and they all said cookies you know the
last one wins if you are hitting this
limit so you should make sure the
cookies stays small okay it's also
really hard to to troubleshoot and I can
tell you so one option that actually is
fully supported by Microsoft and comes
out of the box is just plugging in a
radius cache instead so that instead of
putting all the data under the cookie
they just put a guiit in the cookie and
the gue it has a representation in the
cache and when the cookie comes in they
get the data from the cache in you know
your application is unaware of that it's
happening in the pipeline so to speak
yeah that's that then let's talk about
external authentication so external
authentication is a special case if you
like because now you have to deal with
two systems right there's a wire between
you and the authentication system so an
external authentication process
typically looks like first you challenge
which means you send to user somewhere
else you like to Google or to your
companies of authentication system and
then you're waiting for a callback
coming back from from this external
system and then the callback is doing
all of the protocol work to validate
what what's coming back but validating
tokens and someone's our fourth ma'am
again this is completely abstracted you
don't need to know how these things work
unless you want to know how these things
work which is always a good idea but
again they're just having you know you
saw the five methods yeah so challenge
is the thing that does the sending away
and the callback is implement by the
handler as well and that's a very
typical configuration if you're
connecting to an open body connect based
system yeah where you basically have the
cookie which is the session management
mechanism and then below that you're
configuring your open and the open that
you connect Handler and you know
typically the only really things you
need to know here is the so-called
authority which is the base address of
the server your client ID your client
secret if you have one and then all of
that has been taken care of for the
handler itself and the very last thing
before I show you the how it all works
together is API of indication right so
Microsoft ships support for chasing DEP
tokens so if you're doing that that's
already in the box there's another
mechanism for APF or token validation
which is called introspection which
basically means it's not a JSON web
token that the format is proprietary so
you contact the token service on a
back-channel sent that proprietary thing
they get the claims back in return
that's a standard protocol that doesn't
exist in a sink or I've written handler
for that but that you can get under this
URL here and you can plug that in and
make that work as well so that was a
little gap I think okay so let's do this
I'll get rid of this just grime and this
one
and go here so what we have here
basically is an application which you
know let's go to startup it's an
application you know that uses open MIDI
connect for authentication and it uses
cookies for session management and
there's also an API did I want to call
so let's run this first to see how that
works
so you see basically the from from a
programming model point of view here's a
controller on that controller oh yeah I
should mention that we have we have a
authorization policy set up here which
requires authenticated users so whenever
I click something which is protected
yeah that the handler will kick in and
will send me to my authentication system
so let's do that click on the secure
link ok and now I'm sent to some
external system that is using automatic
connect I login doing some consent here
and I'm coming back
and remember that the callback
implementation is done in the handler as
well this produces a claims principle
for me sets the cookie and now I have
the identity of the user available in in
my application
remember that did I mention that there
are two parts to it one is the claims
and one is the metadata off the off the
authenticated user so to speak so the
upper part are the claims and you see
that that stuff coming from the token
service yeah my subject ID my name and
my family name and my email address and
these things and when we look at the
properties here that is the metadata I
mentioned earlier and here you can see
that Microsoft internally is using that
to do some bookkeeping on the session
and as you can see they don't care too
much but cookie sizes because that
cookie is pretty big now but there are
ways to optimize that but you see
basically they have a couple of things
in there like for example the tokens
right I mean the result of that
authentication process were tokens these
are the artifacts yeah we have an
identity token for the session
management we have a access token for
the API access and we have refresh token
so we can keep this token alive
you know in the back background and by
default as you can see they're just
storing all of that in the session so
the typical idea is now when you want to
call an API for example yeah all you
need to do is there's my home controller
yeah you reach into the session they
have an extension method for that on the
HTTP context you just just take it give
me it give me the token okay and then
they you know wherever you store that
that's abstract to you you get back an
access token for the current user and
then you can use that to to call your
API now so that's one piece of the
puzzle we can see if there's actually
working let's start the API as well yep
Oh
okay so that's working so let's have a
look at the API really quick so here's
the API and you can see here we have
this chaat bearer token handler which
again points to the token issuer it says
okay my name is called API so only the
tokens in with an audience of API and
again same idea token comes in handler
does the heavy lifting for you turns it
into a claims principle and the claims
principle is is your user object so to
speak in your controller okay okay but
there's more so I mentioned here that
here are your tokens right and one of
the common that one of the common
problems with token based systems is
well they expire right so a token might
have a lifetime of one hour or you know
one minute up to you really yeah but
there will be property situations where
you want to use the token and it's
expired so you have to find a way how to
refresh that token in the background and
get a new one and that's obviously a
security mechanism because that gives us
the ability to revoke the tokens right
and there are many many ways how to
implement this background token
management one way for example which I
like is by using Microsoft session
management feature yeah
so let's see no that's the wrong one
yeah here so basically you can tap into
the lifetime event as I said of the
session management and one of these
events is called validate principle and
this is called every time the could the
cookie comes in so what I can do now is
for example look at the tokens in the
session get see if I have a refresh
token check the expiration of the
current token and if I reach a certain
threshold
I will under the covers basically
refresh the token and exchange the old
access token with the new access token
in the session and your application code
is completely unaware that this happened
it just says give me a token give me a
token and someone else is working hard
under the covers to
keep this token fresh okay the same
thing we can do at sign-out time here
yeah so when the user is signing out the
session gets destroyed it would be good
security hygiene to revoke that token
right you don't need it anymore so make
sure it's invalid and that's what this
piece of code here is doing No
so if all of that is working and I
talked long enough my token is expired
okay so this access token here is
expired so when i refresh the page what
we should see is is that the exit token
changes also the expires at should go
into the future let's try that oh that
was a bad demo and I can still call my
API okay so that still works I can
guarantee you that it worked because my
token only lasted for 60 seconds so I
think I talked more than 60 seconds then
but yeah it's not there a better way to
show that to you maybe just refresh the
browser
nope okay anyways you have to believe me
I guess okay so that is the the whole
summary of the authentication thing yeah
handlers the authentication service
session management external
authentication API access that's the
whole package yeah shut that down so
next topic authorization so now you know
who the user is now you want to find out
what is this guy allowed to do now it
turns out it was really easy for
Microsoft to innovate in this area
because they had nothing before so
everything is better so I've been giving
feedback for a long long time to das
building a team that their authorization
story is really bad and I have seen so
many homegrown implementations of all
the things and it kind of helped that a
good friend of mine joined a spirit net
team recently well not recently a couple
years ago as to security p.m. but
finally somebody was listening to me no
so a couple of a couple of observations
yeah the way many people did
authorization is using what you think
the authorized attribute right and and
that led to really bad code
maintainability having all of these
attributes sprinkle you know
authorization logic and business logic
in the same place because it was so
limited people wrote their own
authorization attributes and guess what
you have to know the magic keystrokes to
make this work here because you have to
know do I call the base class first or
do I call it afterwards and it turns out
in code reviews even internally at
Microsoft many teams have implemented
the authorization attribute in the wrong
way and they produced
security problems yeah so one of the
goals was well a couple of goals here
first first goal is separate your
authorization logic from the business
logic don't allow custom authorized
attributes anymore and my favorite one
is make it testable right I want to
write some tests to verify that my
authorization rules actually work okay
which is
thing it's a huge topic okay and if you
are if you want to learn more about that
go go to this website here that's the
guy
Barry dorrance from from Microsoft he is
the owner of that system he wrote a
little workshop thing that you can
follow along it's pretty good so there
were logically two things here one is
called policy based authorization one is
called resource based authorization they
are slightly different ways to look into
things let's let's have a look at
policies first so the idea with policies
is is that you're defining a so-called
authorization policy and with that is
really a list of so called requirements
so you know to manage a customer you
need to be authenticated you need to be
in the sales department and you have a
need to have a status of senior ok
that's the that's the policy and then
you can still use the authorized
attribute if you want to but then you
just pass in the name of the policy and
that will every time somebody calls that
method the policy will get executed ok
so two things here first of all
separation of concerns if you have to
change the policy you don't have to
change your controllers they just get
that I think that's it that's my oh yeah
and and and you separate these things
from from each other ok the next thing
which I actually even prefer is you can
also pramatta cailli talk to the
authorization system without having to
use the authorized attribute right so
there's an i offer ization service in in
the di container you can get a hold of
that you call authorize a sync on it you
pass in the claims principle you want to
run the authorization rules against
which is actually a pretty powerful
feature it can be your current user it
can be also a different user in the
system that you want to authorize
against there think of admin portals and
other things yeah and then you pass in
the name of the policy and you get back
basically a true or false and this is
also the key to testability
you can now write tests that create
claims principles of certain shapes
yeah like different types of users you
have in the system you run it for the
policy and you make sure it's returning
the expect
results and if someone you know six six
months down the line changes your code
he will get immediate feedback if he
broke any of the policies for example
yeah which I think is really really
important what else do we have
oh yeah one issue I have here is which
is more like a perception issue this
this kind of gives you the impression to
use this authorization system you need
to have claims for everything right a
claim for this and they claim for that
and they claim for you know everything
it's very tempting to do that right
because you have this shiny new hammer
and everything becomes a nail suddenly
but you should you know claims describe
the identity of the user not what he's
allowed to do identity should be the
input to the authorization system yeah
and the output should be the
authorization decision ma'am
so most documentation you see give you
the impression that's how it works and
then people start modeling everything as
a claim which I think isn't a good fit
yeah so it turns out you can write your
own requirements okay so this one is a
chopp requirement yeah so maybe imagine
you have a controller that should only
be available to managers okay pretty
boring example but you know that's how
it is and basically what you can do is
you can write your own handler in the
system that gets called at runtime they
pass you in the details of the
requirement and then you can do whatever
you want whatever logic you want to run
to determine if this user is allowed or
not and you see it is I organization
service I have here in the constructor
since these things live in the DI
container you can have arbitrary other
dependencies from the DI container to
abstract your data access right and that
again helps with testability as you can
have an AI you know like amok or
organization service and the real one
goes to your database or to your API so
whatever so that's quite cool the second
one is called resource based
authorization and the idea is you know
like the policies only look at who is
the user right where is the resource
based authorization adds one more
dimension to it basically which says and
what is heat
to manipulate in the system okay so
imagine you have you're writing some
sort of customer management things we
have customers and contracts and orders
for example yeah so you would abstract
away all of your objects into so-called
authorization handlers one for customers
one for orders and one for contracts I
guess and then you know you could
encapsulate that in your in in these
handlers when you then call them the
handler gets to see the actual instance
of the resource the user is trying to
manipulate and then you know you can do
authorization rules based on that you
know and then you could call it
something like this right you update a
document you call authorize a sync you
pass in the user you pass in the
document he's trying to update in this
case right and then you know maybe the
rule is you can only update documents
that you've written in the first place
right and that's something you can now
encapsulate in in that system so again a
pretty big improvement and maybe saves
you from writing your own you know
custom system okay
I think of a demo for that as well yeah
so that's um you see here I'm having a
couple of authorization rules here one
is basically saying yes something that
only sales people can do apparently yeah
some something that only sales senior
people can do and something only did the
Deaf interns are allowed to do yeah and
you see here is also an example of you
know required top-level it must be a see
EXO type of person to actually you know
be allowed to do this yeah and then and
then you can go to your controllers or
to your code Rada
where am i oh yeah mam and annotate your
actions with these things obviously you
wouldn't use strings here but constants
and so on here's an example how to do it
imperative Lee as opposed to
declaratively ma'am
yeah so when I run that I have a couple
of different users I think alias is a
salesperson okay yes she is sales yeah
so
if Alice tries to do something that only
saves people can do that's allowed if
she tries to do something that only
sales senior people can do that should
work as well yep
and but if she tries to do the deaf
interns thing like play the Xbox or
something and it's access denied
okay so yeah that that's Justin you know
a quick glimpse into that obviously
there is much more to learn about these
things but you know it's meant to be an
overview the next thing you should be
aware of if you're designing a system
with Ethernet is called asp.net identity
it's Microsoft's user management library
and it has been around for many years
and the first couple of versions were
not that great to be honest there we
gave a lot of feedback and it took a
long time but with the latest version or
the latest two versions I think it's
pretty solid it's pretty good and it
saves you a ton of work if you have to
build an account management system like
with names and passwords you know
imagine all the complexity here creating
the user creating the password saving
them storing them securely resetting
passwords changing passwords email
confirmation multi-factor authentication
you know all the things you have to do
it's all in there and it's you know it's
been reviewed by security people if it
follows best practices and so on so if
you have the luxury of building your own
use a database and most people I know
already have once okay so but if you
have to
well luxury's may be the wrong word and
but if you really have to I would
totally recommend using this library
ma'am
I even have customers that slowly
migrate you know like on the login page
user comes in he locks in they first
checked the old database if the user
exists they might create him over to the
new database using this just to get the
benefits of all the extra things like as
I said changing passwords resetting
passwords you know all the the ceremony
around out sending emails with tokens
taking a link coming back you know it's
a lot of work okay so
the last missing piece so to speak is
here so Microsoft has Microsoft has this
a spirit core that's great yeah they
have an identity management library
that's great too the only thing they
were missing is basically now is the you
know can we now participate in
token-based authentication in the sense
of issuing tokens so that we can secure
api's and that was always missing or
they had a couple of attempts to do that
but it finally came to their senses and
talked to the right people I guess so
that's the the only new thing I can
really show you because it's the only
new thing right now is starting with
dotnet core or a spirit core Frio
preview free whenever you are doing API
of indication yeah like in the API
template or in the spar template
whatever they now incorporate identity
server the thing I'm working on in the
templates so that end and the idea was I
mean you know you could do that since
forever but the idea is now that this
makes it easier for you to get started
because there is a certain amount of
configuration you have to do in in
identity server and and that these are
just keystrokes right but you need to
know why you're doing it now and the
idea of Microsoft is you know what while
I'm talking
I should load this the idea is that
basically you get a file new project
experience it has an API in it it has a
spa in it it has identity server in it
the spa is set up to do open MIDI
connect and OAuth to get a token and to
use this token to access your API s and
you're automatically following the best
practices thing you don't you know come
up with your own security our
infrastructure you don't try to abuse
cookies for things that they are not
meant to and then you can grow from
there now obviously a single project
containing everything is not really
realistic but you know if you just want
to get started that's good and then you
can start separating the things that
separate the API from the UI and you
know and so on so
you wouldn't believe how long it took
Microsoft to finally accept the fact
that maybe an open source solution is
the better one than building it
themselves ma'am
and we had many many discussions with
them and one of the main things is
microphones to have it in cero config
okay so basically no one needs to
understand what they're actually doing
just press f5 so let's have a look at
that so that's the new angular template
in that's the new angular template so
today they would have a couple of
templates they're using that the first
one is the angular 1 and the react one
I'm pretty sure there will be a place at
one at some point and the eighth and the
web api wants as well so you can see
here basically what they're doing is
they're just bringing the pieces
together really so here is where they
add their default UI for registering
users for logging in for logging out all
these things write this and basically
now they are marrying this together with
identity server and here's the magic
extension method that Microsoft wrote
yeah which is the zero config one okay
so under the covers they're wiring up
all the things now the keys the clients
the resources and everything okay so
let's run it it's actually amazing how
much work is needed to run an angular
application these days look at that
compiling stuff it's also amazing i when
you create this template and you run it
for the very first time it has an NPM
restore so it has sixty thousand files
yes it's complete madness yeah
anyways so I'm logged in okay so you see
if basically you get this basic template
here when you click register it just
goes to your register page I guess
that's not exciting when you click login
they do a couple of clever things here
so basically they also took our
JavaScript client library and wrapped
that up as a angular component and as a
react component so when you press login
what they first try to do is open the
pop
and the idea is if you get away with a
pop-up then you don't have to reload all
of your state in your spa when you come
back from your vindication server which
is often a point of criticism right that
you have to go to another site and come
back and depending on how complex your
state is you need to store it somewhere
and it takes a long time and so on so
they first try to do a pop-up if the
pop-up is not allowed maybe on a mobile
device or maybe because of a pop-up
blocker then they do the front channel
redirect to the server and come back to
you switch you know I think you can
configure it but I think that was that
made sense to me I mean I don't know
anything about front-end development but
it looked it sounded reasonable okay so
I can log in now identi server under the
covers it's doing all its magic it's
validating the the request and and the
user and creating tokens and so on so
now basically all we need to do now is
write api's right here's a controller
hold on where is my am i assemble data
controller sorry here it is okay so all
you have to do basically is just put
your authorized attribute there and the
client side will now send the access
token and yeah and we get finally that
the values controller is gone we now get
better data exciting though okay so
that's a quick preview I mean you can
play around with these things today you
have to you have to install HP nut core
preview free for that 3.0 preview free
with Visual Studio 2019 which I think
will next week go RTM so it's pretty you
know it's happening soon okay there are
more plans around this feature area then
just doing the spar template think of
microservice architectures where you
have many api's talking to other api's
so we will work on things like
separating the api is from the identity
server deploying them in different ways
but also a really interesting thing we
are we will do is imagine you bring up a
new API
and normally you would no need to go to
identity server register the API
configured to which resources the API
has access to and all these things so
there's a protocol called dynamic client
registration which which we never
implemented but now is the time I guess
so that basically you can have an
architecture where you bring up the API
the API goes to identity server
registers itself okay so no
configuration required at the token
service for the new API and immediately
is able to get tokens from the token
server and can talk to APs
okay so that's pretty much it
what time do we have any questions we
have eight minutes left did you have any
questions no I have stickers not many to
be honest they are normally I always
forget to bring them out this time I
even forgot to bring them here so but I
but I have a couple ok so if you want
them otherwise thanks for your time and
have a nice day
[Applause]